days of heavy rain have caused havoc in
the city of durban one of africa's
largest ports
shipping containers have been carried
away or strewn across submerged
motorways
into splits commuters forced to abandon
their vehicles and walk
train services across kwazulu-natal
province have been suspended to clear
the rails after land and mudslides
thousands of houses and informal homes
have been damaged and families displaced
jamba pulled his youngest child from the
soil pouring onto his home
i've got no way to go now
i got no house i got no nothing yes my
family is there by my neighbors
we tried to give you the place to
sleep last night we never
we never sleep last night
that thing's very situation is very very
bad
tunze was asleep in his truck and says
he made a narrow escape
at 3am i felt the truck shaking and i
thought maybe someone bumped it when i
opened the curtain i saw the water level
was very high
here in hernandez in durban several
people were killed in the floods
as the water rose some people left the
area seeking safety on higher ground
now they've returned and trying to
salvage whatever they can but there's
very little left with most of the area
covered in debris blocking the entrances
to their homes
with the motorways linking the port to
commercial capital johannesburg
submerged underwater global shipping
firm maersk has suspended its operations
the floodings damaged parts of the city
that had just been rebuilt from riots
last july
cleaning up the road after the severe
rain from last night washing down the
bud and the banks of people's houses and
since we've been trying to get people to
come and sort it out no one's come so
the residents are not taking charge
the south african weather service won't
attribute the storms to climate change
but says this kind of rain may become
the new normal in the years ahead
family some of the pictures that we're
seeing in your report they're absolutely
extraordinary i understand that the
south african president has been touring
some of the areas what's his reaction
been
well so far what we've heard from
president sula ramaphosa is that he said
that this is a tragic toll of the force
of nature and the situation calls for an
effective response by government in
partnership with communities but just
where we are here in ananda we see that
communities really are on their own we
have a group of men trying to fix
a water pipe to bring and distribute
water across this community that's been
badly affected we're standing on a steep
incline where water has gushed down
washing away homes
destroying property and at least two
deaths in this area alone we know the
death toll sits at about 60 at the
moment we know that communities have
come together to either distribute food
or help people uh retrieve or look for
people who are missing uh there's a
report of one man for instance who had
to walk 10 kilometers with the body of
his child who had died in the flooding
simply because he couldn't get the help
that he needs and even here we saw
rescue services arrive hours after they
were first called and the rain is
beginning to come down once again and
even then uh not it wasn't um it was
predicted quite that way only saying
that perhaps we'd have rain on the
weekend we've seen that happening again
now so it's likely that the communities
here will find themselves in an even
worse position in the days to come yeah
and it sounds like we're going to hear
more of those tragic stories as well
famine miller joining us from durban
family thank you very much indeed